let's get back to Brighton and the
Labour Party conference because we're
joined now by the former foreign
secretary and deputy Labour leader Dame
Margaret Beckett thank you very much for
being with us
now I'm keen to talk to you about brexit
but before we get there I just want to
find out about some of the movement
shall we say internal wranglings that
the Labour Party has been going through
the last couple of days because you're
on the National Executive Committee when
you're at the meeting when Jon's
Landsman filed this motion to get rid of
the post of deputy leader effectively
I'll sting Tom Watson no I was on the
m25 so you were stuck he's stuck for a
long time and what do you make of that
move I thought it was very unwise as I
think most people now agree because and
it's not an attack in any way it's
inevitable that you in the media are
talking about that and as John Ashworth
said very Abele earlier on that's not
what we all need to be talking about
because that's not what we're here for
you were stuck in them 25 and Tom Watson
herself couldn't even be at the meeting
because of childcare reasons oh it
sounds a bit like a cave no I think it
was just one of those things it seemed
to John like a good idea so he suggested
it do you think it's quite a ball that
Jeremy Corbyn didn't know what was
happening if Jeremy was supposed to keep
abreast with every little thought or
idea and the John Landsman is thought of
he'd go crazy well let's move on to
practicality and Labour's current
position on breakfast is to try and win
a general election obviously and try and
renegotiate a brexit deal and then have
a second referendum which remain and
leave on the ballot paper but it hasn't
said crucially in which way it would
campaign is that acceptable well it's
what that's one of the things that we're
going to have to stretch out and there
isn't any doubt there'll be different
points of view I think it's entirely
understandable whichever side of the
discussion the argument you come down on
everybody's really worried about what's
happening in their constituencies what
could happen in their constituencies
depending on how things go and I'm
really sincere and wanting to get the
best way through and I think Jeremy's
been quite smart
actually in concentrating on trying to
keep people to bring people together and
to keep people together there may come a
point when we have to make more of a
choice that's exactly the kind of thing
what's your view my view I'm afraid is
is very clear you like everybody else or
most people anyway
in 2016 I accepted that we were going to
leave the European Union I listen to all
the things that were said by the then
Prime Minister about how you should stay
close and you know have a good
constructive relationship and preserve
as much as we could of what was good
about our being in the European Union
and I swallowed all that and then
suddenly she steps forward and Lancaster
House and lays down all these totally
unrealistic crazy red lines that would
would likely to destroy many of the
advantages and benefits
we'd had from being in the European
Union and from then on for me really it
was downhill all the way because the
more it went on and the more to my mind
dangerous it got the more worried I was
about whether there was a credible deal
and you know I I spent many years 10 or
11 in the cabinet and most of them
negotiating in in the European Union or
on behalf of the European Union and the
idea that we would be in some way linked
to and bound to the rules and
regulations that the European Union step
sets on all sorts of good things workers
protection environment was on without
having any say of them without even
being in the room the ball I thought
about that law I panicked so I am now
the view personally that we of course
must ask the people whether this is
still what they had in mind and then in
in that conversation I would say we
should stay because none of the deals on
offer not one of them there's any
comparison to the deal we have now but
look if you just look at what's
happening with the Lib Dems and who were
polling within touching distance at
labor
are you not worried that by not taking a
more decisively remained position labor
are out of step with the members but
also a lot of your voters yes I am
worried about that and I think everybody
is nobody has the right answer here
there are difficulties on all sides
everybody's really worried about what's
the best way to stance to take what's
the best way to approach it and that's
what we're here to discuss and thrash
out at this conference so yes I can't
worry about that but I completely accept
the legitimacy of the argument by people
who say that's the best thing to do
Jeremy Corbyn won't even say if he would
vote leave or remain in a referendum is
that a problem oh you know if you're
trying to say as he is let's not close
the door for people and irrespective of
their point of view then you're bound to
end up saying we'll hang on a minute we
don't have to decide that yet but now
whether that would work whether it is
credible whether it's whether the
electorate would accept it that's
exactly the sort of thing we're trying
to thrash out this week now you were
first elected to Parliament in 1974 that
means you've seen Howard Wilson
Tony Blair led with two big election
winners in action in absorbs the Mori
poll out this week says that Jeremy
Corbyn has got the lowest approval
ratings of any opposition leader all the
way back to we're not Serb it began in
1977
what is going on
well Jeremy is an unusual leader he
comes through a very different
background in politics through most of
the previous leaders and he has heard I
think I know this is a complaint in you
this is the water we swim in but he has
had I think an unusually and continually
harsh treatment by some elements in the
news media and obviously that doesn't
help is the brexit position a lot of the
problem as well what some people see is
a lack of clarity it could be you know
some people like to be able to read what
they want into what people say others
want a clear now I want to know make
this or that it could be one of the
difficulties but I don't want to over
egg this because I think it would be a
big mistake
no general election is like the previous
general election there isn't any doubt
in 2017 when people saw Jeremy if you
like more unfettered that there was a
very different reaction to him and I
know many of the people around Jeremy
are hoping that would be the case again
I certainly hope so too but for me it's
a very clear simple equation there is
only one Prime Minister in Britain is it
going to be Boris Johnson or is it going
to Jeremy Corbyn and I know where Mike
Ross is going just finally I'm talking
about the next prime minister there has
been some talk about a government of
national unity if Boris Johnson resigns
or if he's forced out and around the
time of the extension or the deadline
for breakfast
I was reading a piece and spectator over
the last couple of days which suggested
that your name was being put forward to
as a potential leader of a government of
national unity I mean is that something
that you would consider if it was a way
to stop the New Deal brexit I haven't
seen this metadata piece and we I mean I
completely understand the my government
my people looking at all what's going on
start talking about a government of
national unity I have to admit I'm not a
great believer and it's likely both
myself so I haven't spent any time I'm
agonizing over whether I would but you
would always help
I never rule anything out in politics
but I think a government of national
unity is pretty unlikely and we do
actually have a candidate for Prime
Minister thank you very much our
demographic for being on the program